hi I'm Christopher hin today we're going
to be talking about my fifth Kumi Joe
which is cyto Sensei uh seventh Kum Joe
and that's kind of true kind of not it
looks fairly different and also looks
different for cyto Sensei depending on
when you're looking at him um the
version that I do looks a lot more like
the version ctoi was doing in the 80s
mid to late 80s um there are other
versions of cyos Sensei 7th that look a
little more like
um his sixth as I interpret it so um
this is the case with all martial art
teachers and you know I think people
forget this it's a good time to talk
about it because as martial art teachers
evolve and learn more they organize
things differently and do things
differently so none nothing's set in
stone where it's like oh that's
Untouchable if a teacher comes across
something in their work and they say I
don't think this is very good then they
change it and that might be a shock to
someone who studied with them 5 years
ago when they didn't teach it that way
and they go oh that's not the way but
it's like well that's how the teacher
evolved to do it this way right so as
long as teachers can explain why they're
doing stuff makes good sense so my seven
looks most similar to cyos senses from
the uh 1980s in there like probably mid
to late 80s and it um also has a
different beginning than cyto synthes
shows and I think it because I mean I
chose to do that because it makes it
more sensible with the form that ceeded
that so the fourth form makes more sense
in conjunction with it and it fits
really nice as to why that would happen
because the way scos since they did it
my opinion is kind of a flawed
strategical idea that's my opinion
without being able to talk to the man
about why he made that decision but as
far as I can tell there's a problem and
we'll talk about that when we get out
there um I'm gonna get Josh over here
we're going to go work
Josh all right so uh right now we're
going to talk about my fifth form which
is is analogous to cyto sensei's seventh
form uh very very similar and it starts
in the joki position all right let's go
and
switch okay the beginning of this form
is exactly like for the previous form to
this so when Josh comes in I do this now
in the last one Josh was going to back
up and use joden guch to hit me in the
head okay now my solution what like what
for that was to be right on top of him
and to shove him in the elbows and push
him back um and also that is a way that
cyos say shows the his seventh form um
earlier and then again sometimes later
uh when he's teaching it so one
variation of his that that actually is
how the end is is to drive him away but
in this the idea is we're here and Josh
is going to stay in tight and he's going
to go to my leg so he joden GES and he
goes to my leg right so he realizes that
I'm going to try and charge him back so
he shortens it so I can't get to his
arms and he goes to hit my leg right now
the reason he chooses my leg is because
at this distance if he J on guch and
went to my head you can see he's in a
bad spot in his weapon he would ra
rather be way out here right so because
of that if he just goes down to my leg
it's okay goes down to my leg he's now
hitting in the ideal spot in his weapon
and it's a better shot right and if he
took my leg out and that'd be really
great for him so he transitions his arms
faster than I can get under them and he
goes for my leg because he's staying in
close to me right so we're here like
this and when he goes to do that I turn
and I defend like this okay now when I'm
doing this I'm stepping back so if I did
my job right I'm probably just getting
out of the way of it but I could not
step back far enough or this could
happen also boom he hits that front leg
so I want to have a defense in place so
you keep scooting away from me so so as
we're here and I see that I step back
and I defend just in case right so I'm
here and this is basically half a get on
Gish okay now from here what Josh is
going to do is use subet he's going to
draw his weapon back and he's going to
hit me in the side is his idea with that
as he does that I turn now this is
fairly different than scy the Sensei 7th
scy the Sensei does a different thing
but uh I think this is a really good
thing to show we won't see this specific
movement until the 31 Kum Joe but I
think it's good to initiate now it's a
good good movement to use right here
okay now from here what I'm going to do
is I'm going to whip his weapon away so
I'm going to go like this and the idea
is I want to clear my space so if I did
a really good job of clearing that I can
maybe pop them up here or do all kinds
of other stuff when I do that though I
just continue on so I go here and I come
back behind here and I get to his legs
and then I hook a leg and I pull it now
scite the Sensei I don't know uh why he
did what he did moving things around I
think however it's good to show the
students that you can entangle legs from
that position however just pulling
someone's leg out you got to be way
freaking stronger than they are to just
pull their leg out um but I'm going to
make a video for you guys later showing
all the ways that you can use those leg
entanglement methods um and it's just a
nice space saver to me for it to show we
could do any of those things here so
we're hooking the legs on that so again
this form starts exactly as four does I
come in here then as he comes to go
there I step back and defend my leg he
comes in for me I turn my hips and catch
the weapon I'm trying to clear my space
and when I do that I come all the way
back here hook that leg and I pull it up
and that is my fifth form an alus cyto
since a seventh form teaches us a lot of
great stuff what if we miss the elbows
when we're trying to catch the bows on
the previous form well this tells us
about it also tells us about making low
leg shots when you're in a crushed in
position right and we're going to see
that again in the next form so if I'm in
a tight position I can use a leg shot
how to one way I can defend against leg
shots and there's a few ways we'll see
and this is the first one we're going to
see defending against leg shots how I
can defend from this kind of position
for anything coming in ski that's taught
here how I can whip the weapon away here
so there's a lot of great stuff in this
form and then all the leg entanglement
stuff as well so that's my fifth form
I'm christop Hines Joshua T my salon
McDaniel is sneaking slowly over to that
camera right there and we'll see you in
the next video